Hello Freak bitches.
You know,
this is going to come a point in time
where human beings have like a biological
meeting and we decide now that
we have genetic engineering,
should we decide to
continue with this shape?
Should we decide to
What is love?
What is beauty in the eye of the beholder?
Could we all be better off
if we're flying jellyfish,
they'd come up with this proposition
to be able to replace a with a simple
prescription,
uh,
any feelings of love or sex or
affection that people need or want,
it's all satiated.
You,
you never have to worry about reclaiming
that again and that the most harmonious
shape for the universe,
the most harmonious shape
to coexist forever with a,
an infinite lifespan is flying jellyfish.
How long before we'd be all be
flying jellyfish seven years.
The way that thing just flew,
I want it to be that thing.
I know it's threw it off a bridge,
which someone gets really just throw
you off a bridge and you just show this.
And this is the,
imagine that technology in 20 years where
that thing is following you around all
day long,
all night long.
Imagine that in the shape of Dicks,
imagine once they figure out to the
shape of a dick is really not perfect.
You know?
And just like there's other shit that's
wrong with people like the fact that so
easy to knock us out.
Yeah,
that's a big flaw.
Punched him in the chin.
They go unconscious as a stupid flaw.
What if they realize like
dicks are good but have a seat.
I'm going to show you the new,
we're going to show you the next level,
the next level,
some sort of new thing.
It gets inside you and just expands,
expands like a fist.
So in a few little dicks
all around at Tube,
like the main Dick tube and
it's spreads out like corn.
And I want to talk a little decks inside.
I think.
Imagine if your Dick was,
uh,
this might be the dumbest
thing I've ever said.
Imagine if your Dick was like an ear
of corn and each one of those little
kernels was another dick.
And once your Dick got in
there and we had dick was hard,
you dick got in there,
then all those little dicks would
pop out and we would all like,
they would all play music
inside the girl's Vagina,
not downtown,
downtown dumped.
Um,
and that would be the thing,
like girls could come the hardest.
You've made the best
music inside the vagina.
Oh,
Joe.
That's what I'm saying.
Right.
Listen,
that's a very important point.
If you just assuming that the Dick shape
that we have currently is the best,
but if you got the dick shape we had
currently and the ability to make music
with your deck,
right,
Jamie.
Jamie,
don't look at me like crazy.
Trying to think what kind
of music you mentioned Donk,
Donk,
some Beethoven Shit said a piano
or a violin or mostly like drums,
I guess.
Okay.
Depends on what you're
trying to accomplish.
Yeah.
I'm more of like a a you,
a Bongo player or bass drum.
I could see Jamie playing pong.
Guys had a flirty play,
a gym day that was one of the
most intense title fights ever.
Roy McDonald got you mean they got,
he got so close to winning that title.
He had Robbie Lawler almost knocked out.
He head kicked him Dang dumb.
Robbie was wombling and then Robbie came
back to stop them in the next round and
his nose exploded and he literally
went down in pain and you could see him
writhing on the floor and it looked
like he was just trying to find some
comfort.
Like the pain was so intense when that
broken knows that he was just trying to
find some kind of comfort.
Blood was everywhere and it was just two
guys that push themselves to the brink.
And unfortunately when you see a fight,
what does that,
can you go to the bathroom?
So what you're saying,
just ask,
go ahead.
Go to the bathroom.
Jesus Christ.
Dad,
guys drinking over here.
Chris Palm Coast,
the only one drinking here,
throwing down the booze,
checking his fucking
Twitter every five minutes.
But uh,
the,
it was,
it was a sport or it was a fight rather
with these like you see them here like
writhing in agony like here,
like that is so hard to deal with.
I mean,
he's just looking at him,
he's like,
oh,
he just goes down.
I mean,
he's just in agony.
I mean it's one of the most tense moments
I've ever seen in a fight of just like
the most obvious expression of it,
of pain.
I mean,
look at them here.
It's crazy.
He might not ever be the same.
Yeah.
Neat.
When by the way,
are Robbie too.
That was a crazy fucking fight.
Rory said the next day.
That was the greatest day of his life.
Yeah,
I'm sure that's what kind of,
uh,
that's the,
that's the man he is.
I mean,
he fought his heart out.
There was nothing left for vault of them.
They were so closely matched,
such a good fight.
And in Robbie,
how about when he's screaming in victory
and his lip is split open like a cleft
palate has Lyft has split open
this giant Gash in his lip.
Like look at them.
There's a sideways photo where you see
like a profile picture of him roaring
with his lip split open and it's
this hard to believe that this guy's,
you know,
that he fought like that.
He fought with his lip split wide.
Oh,
if there's a better picture of it,
Jamie for find it.
It's like a sideways angle of the
side where you see the actual uh,
cut itself.
But it was one of the most gruesome
lip injuries I've ever seen.
And you know,
it was the guy who won that,
those guys,
there is where it is.
Dana Dana apparently walked up from
that side right there and said,
oh my God,
don't talk.
Say Man.
Yeah.
I mean his lip was literally
just a giant slice.
Like you get hit with
a hatchet in the face.
It was crazy.
It was a crazy,
crazy,
crazy fight.
And one of the most intense closely
match title fights in the Welterweight
Division is history.
Yeah.
I ever,
it was about down to the wire,
I met a woman at one of
my shows in Brooklyn.
She had no hands or feet.
What happened to her?
Well,
she came up to me after the show and
she like wanted to like give me a hug.
She was like,
you're so funny.
And she had like these
stuffs and she said,
you reminded me of the girls who
did my nails when I had hands.
And I was like,
like I said,
tape.
It was like racism,
what the fuck?
Whoa.
I was like,
I was thinking like I want to bring
it up if I just met her any other way.
But since she brought up her hands,
I was like,
what happened to your hands?
And she said that she had,
um,
something wrong with her appendix went
to the hospital and the doctor put the
wrong name,
like mixed up her charts and they
amputated her hands and her feet
when she was only supposed to get
her appendix taken out or something.
Very minor.
Yeah.
And then a few weeks after that
comedy show where I met her,
I saw on the front page
of the paper in New York,
it said so and so,
or whatever her name was.
I forgot her name.
Uh,
given $14 million or whatever,
you know,
like the settlement for
your hands and your feet.
I forget how much it was,
but it was,
it was maybe longer.
And I met her boyfriend
go and you mentioned dating that happening
to your girlfriend and you're like,
yeah,
I'll stick around.
Right.
So crazy.
I asked him,
I said,
how long have you guys been together?
He was like a year when that happened.
Wow.
I was like,
well man,
you're such a good guy.
You know,
she can't even like wipe her ass
or maybe he went to the fucking
hospital and switch the things on here.
She is the founder
all right there.
But you know why she was so,
it's just so bizarre.
She was so happy that like,
you know,
you wonder like how,
how she can be happy.
But she was so like,
she was in such a good mood.
Like she was just like
loving the comedy show.
She was so appreciative and like
she was having a great time.
Wow.